roller man jean-yves brodo is trying out
some blades he shoots down the icy track
at 70 km/h like a human bobsled his head
just 10 centimeters from the ice he
calls this brand new version of buggy
rollin the extreme sport he invented
buggy ice
the perfect feeling is a flying feeling
when you make mistakes you hear that the
noise is changing when the when every
blade is on the right position it just
make when something's wrong
I sunfire in Segura de la fere some 50
kilometers east of the capital Riga
adrenaline junkies come here to race on
skates or hurdle down the luge at
breakneck speeds and he is the craziest
of them all Jolly Bronto from France his
full body suit is studded with 14 ice
skate blades a prototype that's only
been tried once before the first session
I had which I loved is in the curve you
watch and then you see the people are
wrong direction the trees going over you
and the sky is wrong direction so so
it's the world is changing around you
because of the gravity direction
this is jolly abroad Oh in the original
version of his suit as the roller man he
reached speeds up to 120 kilometers an
hour the 32 rollers let him across
smooth surfaces in every conceivable
position
it may look pretty dangerous but it's
meticulously planned out sometimes I go
even by foot to know each corner it's
trap it's it's crossword so I know
everything in my head I can visual in 3d
how the street looks like so it's a
question of preparation you don't go
just like this Johnny you bronto and
bettered is 32 wheel roller suit over 20
years ago while studying industrial
design now he's selling his invention so
much of it has to be done by hand but
the suit costs around six thousand seven
hundred euros he also earns money with
TV appearances and advertising even if
he makes a living from his invention
rondo says it's not primarily about
money
when you wear the suit the first time
your connection to the world is changing
you are not you're not a normal human
everything you touched in touch with the
wheels it looks more robotic deeply your
identity the image you sent to the other
people is different
[Music]
over the years Bronto is refined his
suit more and more modifying it for a
variety of surfaces this is the ski
version and he's got his sights set on
new goals as well I think we can go like
easily fifty-fifty converter more with
good aerodynamics to work on
aerodynamics I would like to work with
some motors inside like electric motors
my dream is to be faster than the
current street even a flat I want that I
can produce the suits cheaper that for
Christmas skip can choose two bites
there's no doubt that the suit is a real
eye catcher
and it may well be the most impressive
and dangerous way to speed down a luge
you
[Applause]